[Music]
okay kobe
he is just walking around in his tiny
whities on tv i can see why
so
what do you think emily and kobe react
to getting it in after two years apart
[Music]
speaking of baby making music if you
haven't you have to see kobe's reaction
to meeting his son cobin for the first
time
can get my height together
i mean that moment was something else
plus
while saying their final goodbyes to him
as he leaves for america
i think that whatever issue that they
have first they need to work stuff out
with biddy but
and ari reveals where her relationship
currently stands with his sisters
after wish threw wine in her face
i figured something might happen
i didn't expect that let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia this
week was a pretty emotional episode
at least i was in my feelings
let's kick things off with emily and
kobe's steamy knight
i haven't seen you in like two years
that means we haven't had sex in two
years after picking kobe up from the
airport emily suggests that they have a
date night before she takes them home to
meet his son cobin
and although kobe is hesitant at first
because he wants to see his son i want
to see my son
please
now he's saying this date night was the
best night of his life
these are moments where i wish i could
see your faces
good morning
cheers
so
so
what do you think
oh my god babe
damn babe you're ready
we could do it in the shower like i can
try and ride i think this was a great
night oh the greatest you go girl so you
don't regret like i don't regret it okay
i'm not going to lie some of that
footage took me by surprise
i was like okay 90 days you know before
kobe got to america emily was concerned
about how he would react to her mom-bod
but she was worried for no reason
we had sex once outside in the shower
and then twice this morning wait
my bad but do you ever wonder when the
cameras leave
this is the moment when they were
getting in the shower
we could do it in the shower like i can
try anyway at what point do the camera
people and producers say
okay
let's excuse ourselves we'll lock the
door behind us okay
this is getting a little awkward for me
now anyway back to how kobe made emily
feel he made me feel so comfortable in
my body that i'm you know that i have
now like made me feel so loved like he
didn't not touch me i mean i don't
really think we got into the boobs a
whole lot we just kind of you know stuck
down low and i wasn't sure you know how
i was gonna feel with my mom bog and his
dad pod but
it worked
when i chatted with emily and kobe last
month
he mentioned that in a situation like
this it's the man's responsibility to
help the woman feel confident about her
body well you as a man you have to
understand the sacrifices that you know
a woman is made especially in getting
that weight so you have to make her get
confidence in herself you know i mean
most women after gaining weight they
have like kind of stuff like little
service team but as a man you need to
figure it out on how you can do the boss
hamara's up you know despite the fact
that she's gained weight so i try as
much as i can to make that happen with
her
if only all men thought like that i know
some of y'all are thinking he's probably
just saying that because it sounds good
but
i think he really means it
ready all right
can't wait to meet my son
all right now to the moment i've been
waiting for since the season started
kobe's finally meeting cobin and he's
extremely excited and anxious
and get this when they pull up to
emily's house he breaks down crying at
just the thought that he's about to see
his child's face in person for the first
time
get the welcome
babe are you crying
kobe
look at me
oh
i need
[Music]
maybe deeper babe take a deep breath
you're like hyperventilating
kobe pulls himself together and when
they walk in the house he tries to keep
his composure
but then cobin and all of his
adorableness does this
you see
papa you see dada
oh my god you'll be shy
can you get my height together
[Music]
[Laughter]
the baby is like what's going on
[Laughter]
who's that guy
oh
look he's looking at you
oh my god
who is that so cute he looked just like
you
wow kobe literally burst into tears
literally
getting to meet colin for the first time
i couldn't take it like he was just so
sweet like
i'm a dad today because of him like
it was just a very beautiful moment
it was
from the looks of it kobe has such a
gentle heart
a gentle man is everything
oh emily girl you lucked up in that
random bar in china for real
thank god he is as great as he is
because i could have ended up with
someone you know
totally opposite of him and i like to
this day i am mind blown emily's parents
are touched by kobe's emotional reaction
to seeing cobin
when kobe was crying that was really
touching i want to just kind of make him
feel welcome and while the baby is
acting a little shy toward him kobe
takes it all in stride he's just happy
to be there
he's just a baby so he tried to shy away
from me but you know
i need to do so much to catch up for all
times that i've not been around
for him to feel like you know i'm his
daddy i love it i love it i love it it's
so sweet
alright in true binium fashion i took
you high now i'm about to take you low
they're so happy and then i will tell
them just
after he threw a party to tell his
family he's moving to the u.s the day
before he leaves and after his sister
wished through wine and ari's face
it's crazy the time has come for binium
to say goodbye to his siblings
so before his flight he meets up with
them solo for lunch
[Music]
and his sister wish who threw the wine
says ari is the one who needs to
apologize
unless you have to say sorry
about
this do you need to say sorry no
no 100 though
she said like we're not important after
we've done everything to her like it
hurts me it hurts binyam asked his
sisters and brother to come to the
airport later on that night to say their
final goodbyes
and they come but his sisters make it
clear
that they don't even want to see ari
benny we don't want to face a lot
that's not nice
all right i'll move
so ari got in the car with her child
and stayed there
can you give me avi
no no no no no no no no i won't put him
in the car i don't know if you want no i
think it's cold outside just let him
leave him when binyam's sister's asked
to kiss avi goodbye binium tries to get
him from the car but ari refuses if
they're not so stupid they can come and
see him but their behavior is really
stupid so he tells his sisters the baby
is asleep
and they knew that was a lie
i mean i cannot believe she don't you
know
let us say by abby he's like our kid
so that hurt that hurt a lot
yeah if i were them i would have put my
pride to the side and been cordial just
for a minute so i could say bye to my
nephew
i got the gist that ari only said no
because of the energy they brought to
the airport
benny we don't want to face daria low
either way wish and mimi both start
crying and mimi goes on to make a bold
statement
you know
i'm slow to speak on family situations
like this because the reality of it is
is that we only see a very small portion
of these people's lives
bennium's sisters claim he's really not
happy
so they may know something that we don't
know
or they could just be messy or hurt
or all of the above
we also have to keep in mind that as a
family they have been through a lot
nothing
tonight
[Music]
i'm guessing they mean he's stuck in a
relationship with ariella because of avi
you made your bed you lie in it but
besides that me me opening up about
losing their parents at a young age
got to me
i put myself in their shoes for just a
moment
and to think that for years they've been
all each other has
now their brother is leaving for another
country and it seems as if all this is
happening because of one woman
that they don't even get along with
that's enough to make you bitter
look at this shot look at their faces
look at the little boy's face
although i do not agree with his
sister's behavior as someone who does
not play about their family
this hit a soft spot
i can see how they think she's the enemy
are you okay
yeah i'm okay
this is very hard for leaving my family
i wish i would take them in the u.s
together so that's what i fear
well in real time benny and ari have
been in the us for a minute now
and during my conversation with him i
asked ari where her relationship with
binium's family stands
specifically with his sister wish
yeah so
she
she doesn't want to talk to me um and
that's okay
personally i think that
uh
i think that whatever issue
that they have first they need to work
stuff out with bitty but to hear more of
that conversation
make sure you subscribe to entertainment
tonight's youtube channel so you don't
miss the interview you can also catch it
on et online.com
all right next week ari and benny land
in new york city
[Music]
and the tables have turned now benny has
to learn how to co-exist with ari's
family
just only wanted
his family it's good for me or it's bad
for me i wanted you to know that you
have a very crazy family yeah and you'll
have to get used to it i guarantee you
no one's going to throw wine in your
face
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
[Music]